Das ist wirklich verrückt an die materie ist ja etwas ziemlich exotische. So ein seltenes eigentlich
Wo sie bisher nur im labor erzeugt und ziemlich selten auch im weltall auf gespürt
Aber das was antimaterie in erheblichen mengen auf der erde geben könnte
Unvorstellbar aber es ist so in einem hurrikan wurde sogar. Eine ganze lawine an antimaterie
Festgestellt wort wie konnte es dazu. Kommen jetzt den klicks, um science-fiction und es gibt am ende etwas
Zu gewinnen 3 x 2 tickets für die lincoln hier in berlin auf die ich mich am wochenende auch schmuggeln werde herzlich willkommen
Erst mal wieder vielen dank für den dem vorschlag auf whatsapp hammer kurz von kommen bevor es
Um die antimaterie geht eigentlich ist die team. Konnte das festival der digital. Jugendkultur. Januar bis 21
aber ich habe ganz doll gebettelt weil ich es
So spannend findet deshalb darf ich jetzt, hin 13 bis 21 ist eigentlich das alter und tickets für die drei tage
kosten nur 15 euro
Die gibt es
Hier bei den condor tork. Und er ist auch übrigens unten in der video beschreibung eingeblendet
Und ich kann euch nur sagen es lohnt sich mega also drauf klicken auf den link in der video beschreibung und mit ein bisschen glück
Könnt ihr hier bei mir am ende des videos 3 x 2 tickets gewinnen zum mega. Spannenden, themas ist das große rätsel des universums
Warum besteht das aus materie und nicht aus antimaterie beim urknall entstand nämlich fast
Genauso viele antimaterie materie aber eben nur fast auf eine milliarde material die
Materie paare gab es. Ein teilchen materie antimaterie
Und materie zu erstrahlten sich und es blieb die. Materie der materie überschuss. Übrig warum weiß keiner
Doch es gibt antimaterie in geringen mengen im universum zum beispiel in gewittern watch schon vor einigen. Jahren
Konnten forschungsteams mit hilfe des fermi teleskops verdächtigen signale auffangen sie richteten
dafür den fermi satelliten richtung erde, er sollte gammablitze
Also energiereiche elektromagnetische strahlung in gewittern untersuchen ja und er, stieß auf etwas absolut verblüffendes
Antimaterie die vermutung blitze produzieren nicht nur energiereiche strahlung sondern lösen auch
kernreaktionen in der umgebenden luft aus die vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler bei dieser zerfallsreaktionen wird antimaterie frei es entstehen sogenannte
positronen also quasi
Positiv geladene elektronen, und zwar wenn energiereiche gammablitze auf atomkerne treffen, denn. Dann kann
ein, antiteilchen paar entstehen also ein elektron materie
Und ein positron antimaterie jetzt haben wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
Erstmalig die schauer der sogenannten positronen direkt im gewitter. Gemessen sie flogen durch den. Inneren wolken des hurrikans
Patricia schon vor drei. Jahren jetzt wurden die ergebnisse veröffentlicht und das ist wirklich irre nicht ein oder
ein paar teilchen antimaterie sondern ganze schauer
das wiederum bestätigt wiederum die theoretische vorhersage die
Bislang über die hoch energetischen vorgängen in den wolken existieren demnach entstehen die schauer von positronen also positiv geladenen elektronen
Wenn, hoch energetische gammablitze durch gewitter erzeugt werden. Konkret. Konnte das messinstrument
Namens adele in einer. Höhe von etwa 200 kilometern das signal eines
Hoch energetischen teilchen strahls auffangen zudem wurden auch
blitze über dem flugzeug registriert dass die positronen nun direkt beobachtet werden
Konnten ist wie gesagt eine absolute sensation eine echte premiere
Doch wie entstehen sie genau nach einem modell dazu durch den. Mechanismus des sogenannten
Relativistischen feedbacks in den gewitterwolken befindet sich. Ein elektrisches feld das die
darin
Enthaltenen elektron beschleunigt je schneller sie werden umso weniger luftwiderstand gibt es eine positive rückkopplung quasi die zu einer lawine von
Elektronen führt, und zwar fast alle so schnell wie das licht diese wiederum schicken. Hoch energetische gammastrahlung zum. Himmel zudem
Und das ist das irre werden paare aus elektronen und positronen gebildet
Genauso wie die elektronen werden die positronen vom elektrischen feld beschleunigt doch eben
Einen unterschied gibt es sie werden in die entgegengesetzte richtung geschleudert sie sind ja auch positiv geladen nämlich zum boden
und so konnten sie überhaupt auch erst vom agilität act or aufgespürt werden ja und jetzt könnt
Ihr die themen contacts gewinnen meldet?
Euch bei whatsapp an und schreibt mir wie das festival der jugendkultur am wochenende in berlin
Heißt gibt es mehrere richtige antworten entscheidet das los die
Gewinnspielbedingungen sind in der video beschreibung verlinkt klicks also hier drauf. Und am besten auch
Meine schwester cara klicks, um social and media abonnieren da erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen
Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch kräftig. So kann antimaterie erzeugt werden bis. Dann
bleibt dran